let's go to tick tock and uh we'll give  them a chance to present their case if  you're American and you think America is  the best country in the world can you  please give me a genuine reason why I  don't know how many times I got to tell  y'all America is a third world country  in a Gucci belt we hate it here too like  we don't want to be here a third world  country uh he says lounging on his bed  in what looks to be a shower cap  recording a video on his 900 phone which  he'll upload using his internet  connection and then spend the day  scrolling the internet playing video  games eating whatever snacks he finds in  his mom's Pantry yeah third world  country